a new study out of Israel found that
video games are actually good for
children yeah everyone says they cause
violence and they make you dumb and
anti-social no not the case and that
they learn stuff a lot of stuff english
math history language space minerals
chemical sciences technology different
countries and cultures how to fish how
to save money how to build how to drive
how to fly and land a plane how to
invest in the stock exchange how to make
ice cream how to shoot how to program
how to search strategize how to solve
problems how to be consistent to
calculate to concentrate how to win and
lose with respect not get in touch with
people I do not know how to play soccer
basketball and how to improve my body
all right that guy was talking pretty
fast so let's give you a little visual
simple one sheet on why video games are
actually pretty good a good storyline
produces a context where kids feel happy
working hard failing up when a gamer
fails they become more creative and
resourceful to get to the next level
games empower children and collaboration
players share a common space and
understanding I'm a big gamer myself so
I love this story forgot number 5 what's
number five kids learn a new way to call
each other names online punk-ass
[ __ ] [ __ ] that happened in that
video was what about the teacher teach
kids good sportsmanship yeah nah roles
are created on Call of Duty what is this
good sportsmanship I'm hearing so much
about right okay so there there of
course there's plenty of that especially
with the online stuff and you can be
screaming people in all kinds of racial
stuff and homophobic and all that good
stuff but on its face value doesn't it
seem pretty good because I feel like
video games get beaten up so much in our
culture we have this huge amount of
people that play halo comes out it makes
400 million in a day and then everyone
blames it for every shooting but it's
showing how problem solving an eye hand
coordination all that stuff is actually
related videos what and we know that it
actually works because you know the
military recruits people who have skills
in video gaming because everything's
remote-controlled so it's not I mean
it's not a complete waste of time and
even from another
a surgeon's there there there there that
starting to dive into remote surgery a
guy from these coasts can do a surgery
in California remotely and you really
you need even steadier hands then
surgeons of old with your scalpel it's
like they're you know there's the
coarser ones play video games these
latest ones we have the slight movement
of the like you know I remember the
entire control you just jam it forward
you don't go as far as possible there
one big red button but now there's
slight movements do huge things and
there's that steady hand in that study
coordination and concentration takes to
do things that are of most importance
when you plan on liners you get called
horrible names yet not called horribly
but it is one of these things where it's
like anything else like if you use it
too much yes you could become antisocial
you could sort of disconnect from the
real world and there are in south korea
i think they have a ton of rehabs four
people that are addicted to game so it's
not all good but in one of these things
or it's about personal choice and if you
use it sort of appropriately i play
video games five hours a day when I was
a kid i'm okay i basically but were you
playing 2d games cuz that's a door i was
playing too deep playing super mario
brothers and that's the thing like you
put me in front of a 3d you know first
person whatever and i'll spend 45
minutes trying to figure out how to turn
away from the wall yeah I don't under I
had soft to people who understand it
it's I'm really bad at it but I think
that you know like it just gives people
like so many things online to give you
permission to be such an abusive
faceless entity that it's just no it's
no good but we're also on youtube and
you you have access to that on YouTube
to to be these talks about not reading
the comment yeah this guy only hears
about stuff from the collarbone down so
I understand but I think that when you
let kids especially have access to each
other without you know without having
without with being able to be anonymous
and being like a shitty teenager because
we were all shitty when we were
teenagers I don't know I just don't know
how help that really helps us is a limit
on anything really it's a matter of I
mean they come of all the things you
learn and you learn a lot of things in
school but you only go there for a
certain number of hours a day you have
to leave you need a change of pace
video games are these different things
that unite ensure your learning and get
dressed our house yeah move a little bit
I like you said about the 2d thing
because I'm thinking like if I grew up
playing let's say Nintendo and Sega
Genesis everything was 2d and you ran
you know right to left basically your
left right and but now that you know
because everything's 3d and you're
running into the screen and all that I
played star wars battlefront a couple
years on PlayStation with my friend who
I grew up playing video games it and his
ten-year-old son was killing us I mean
we literally couldn't get out of a room
we were laughing hysterically because we
used to be kings and now we were getting
abused by cool not know there is a key
about it we ended up going to the store
right after we got one of those
compilation of old games you know can
weaken day anymore but can go simulate
my point is that it may be his
ten-year-old son's brain actually is
able to it's more sophisticated and
evolved quicker because his baseline
he's starting in a 3d world and who
knows what that will lead to I mean we
know we don't know but here the
percentages of our brain we actually use
which is minuscule and so I we're gonna
go to the other reference my
two-year-old son he's got an ipad and
the kid at one was like how much you
stand expanding things yeah the stuff
that didn't exist when you were that you
really want to have fun put a magazine
in front of that guy okay watch them try
to swipe across and see why the pages
aren't turning it's hilarious yours
don't get it they're like cats and
that's because this iPad so why when I
swipe the front of this Cosmo why isn't
anything happening because that's a
thing they're coming in it's such a more
sophisticated level than we are that
that is really interesting that is
really cool and I hate being the cliche
like in moderation but like if you don't
then you just have you know some kid who
doesn't know how to socialize
you